Ehrlich gesagt war das Wochenende
ziemlich interessant, da wir einige
neue Informationen zu Anthropics
nächstem Modell erhalten haben, das
bereits am kommenden Dienstag
erscheinen könnte. Anthropic testet
derzeit im Geheimen Opus 5.5 unter dem
Modell-Slug Claude Opus 5-5 mit dem
Codenamen Claude Wafer EAP.
Interessanterweise wird es nicht mehr
als Opus 5.2 bezeichnet, worüber wir
vor Kurzem berichtet hatten. Dieser
neue Prüfpunkt soll angeblich auf dem
Niveau von GPT-6 Astra arbeiten, was
bemerkenswert wäre, wenn man bedenkt,
dass Opus 5.5 auch ein günstigeres
Preismodell haben soll, worauf wir
später noch eingehen werden. Wir haben
außerdem wichtige Modell-Neuigkeiten
von einem chinesischen KI-Labor
erhalten: StepFun hat die Step 5
Vorschau vorgestellt, ihr neues
Flaggschiff-Modell für die Arbeit der
Gen Z, Softwareentwicklung,
professionelle Wissensarbeit und
insbesondere das Finanzwesen. Das
Verrückte daran ist, dass die Step 5
Vorschau ein MoE-Modell mit 600
Milliarden Parametern ist, von denen
nur 27 Milliarden aktiv sind. Und laut
StepFuns eigener Grafik liegt es etwa
auf dem gleichen Niveau wie GLM 5.3 und
Qwen K3, während es pro Aufgabe
angeblich etwa 65%weniger kostet. Es
sieht auch so aus, als ob MiniMax kurz
vor der Veröffentlichung von M 3.1
steht, und ich habe tatsächlich einige
Insider-Informationen dazu erhalten.
Nach dem, was ich gehört und gesehen
habe, sieht es so aus, als würden sie
das Modell langsam vorbereiten, und es
wird schon bald erscheinen. Vonseiten
Alibabas scheint man die Qwen 4-Familie
vorzubereiten, die möglicherweise auf
der kommenden Aspara-Konferenz
enthüllt werden könnte. Das Timing
würde Sinn ergeben, wenn man bedenkt,
dass frühere Generationen der
Qwen-Modelle im Rahmen von
Aspara-Veranstaltungen vorgestellt
wurden. Und nun wurde auch Coin Image
2.1 veröffentlicht, ein
Open-Weight-Bildmodell mit nur 7
Milliarden Parametern, das für seine
Größe bemerkenswert wettbewerbsfähig
erscheint. Und selbst im Vergleich zu
Modellen wie Google Nano Banana 2
scheint es diese trotz der nur 7
Milliarden aktiven Parameter zu
übertreffen. Und schließlich bereitet
sich ein weiteres chinesisches Labor
auf eine wichtige
Modellveröffentlichung vor, nämlich
Moonshot AI mit dem Start von Kimi Kate
3.1, das möglicherweise bald
erscheinen wird. Wenn die ersten
Informationen zutreffen, könnte dies
ein weiteres leistungsstarkes Modell
werden. Es gibt noch viel mehr zu
besprechen, also lassen Sie uns einfach
direkt einsteigen. Außerdem Leute, ich
habe gelesen, dass 70%von euch
Zuschauern den World of AI
YouTube-Kanal nicht abonniert haben,
und ich weiß, das klingt etwas
kitschig, aber es würde mir wirklich
viel bedeuten, wenn ihr den Kanal
abonnieren würdet. Denn das würde den
Kanal wirklich unterstützen und mir
helfen, jeden Tag Videos zu produzieren
. Aktivieren Sie unbedingt die
Benachrichtigungsglocke, damit Sie
immer auf dem Laufenden bleiben, was in
der Welt der KI passiert. Wenn Sie die
besten KI-Tools, Workflows und
Neuerscheinungen vor allen anderen
haben wollen, abonnieren Sie meinen
völlig kostenlosen Newsletter über
den Link in der Beschreibung unten.
Fangen wir mit Anthropic an, denn es
sieht so aus, als würden sie gerade
einen brandneuen Opus 5.5 Checkpoint
testen. Aktuellen Informationen zufolge
testet Anthropic im Geheimen Opus 5.5,
was bedeutet, dass sie das vorherige
Opus 5.2 EAP-Modell verworfen haben.
Dies ist ein neues Opus 5.5-Modell, das
mit einem neuen Kürzel im Backlog
aufgetaucht ist und unter dem Codenamen
Claude Wafer EAP läuft. Dieser
Checkpoint wird aktiv getestet und soll
Berichten zufolge bereits am Dienstag
veröffentlicht werden. Ich weiß nicht
, ob sie alle Anthropic-Modelle auf
einmal veröffentlichen werden, was wir
uns zuvor erhofft hatten, indem sie im
Grunde ein aktualisiertes Sonnet-Modell
, dieses neue Opus-Modell sowie ein
aktualisiertes Fable-Modell
herausbringen würden. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob sie diesen Plan
verfolgen, aber wir sind uns ziemlich
sicher, dass es höchstwahrscheinlich
Opus ist, das am Dienstag erscheinen
wird. Aber was wir auch über dieses
Modell wissen, ist, dass es eine
unglaubliche Preisstruktur hat, die es
besonders wettbewerbsfähig gegenüber
Astra machen könnte. Denn laut den
durchgesickerten Preisen könnte Opus
5.5 4 Dollar pro 1 Million Input-Tokens
und 20 Dollar pro 1 Million
Output-Tokens kosten, bei 20 Cent für
Cache-Reads und 5 Dollar pro Million
Tokens für Cache-Writes. Sollte dies
zutreffen, könnte diese
Preisgestaltung Opus 5.5 zu einer sehr
interessanten Option machen,
insbesondere wenn seine Leistung
tatsächlich auf dem Niveau von Astra
liegt. Es gibt jedoch eine interessante
Änderung. Das angegebene
Kontextfenster ist tatsächlich kleiner
geworden, und zwar nicht um einen
erheblichen Betrag, sondern nur um eine
geringfügige Verringerung der
Gesamtzahl der Tokens beim neuesten
Checkpoint. Während der Kontext also
etwas kleiner ist, konzentriert sich
Anthropic möglicherweise mehr auf die
Verbesserung der Leistung und die
Senkung der Gesamtkosten. Aber schauen
Sie sich nur den Detailgrad dieses
Modells an. Hier ist es in der Lage,
verschiedene Arten von Objekten in 3
D-Umgebungen ziemlich gründlich zu
verformen und darzustellen. Nun, nicht
alle Funktionen scheinen perfekt zu
funktionieren, wie zum Beispiel die
Räder, aber insgesamt hat es diese
wahnsinnige Simulation oder Demo
generiert, die zeigt, wie das BMW M5-
Modell in einer 3 D-Umgebung aussehen
kann, was irgendwie verrückt ist. Hier
ist nun ein direkter Vergleich mit dem
Opus 5.2. Dies ist ein früherer
Checkpoint von Opus 5.5, aber man sieht
, dass er im direkten Vergleich bei
diesen individuellen Prompts mit GPT-6
Astra mithalten kann, was zeigt, wie
gut die Modelle verschiedene Szenen
darstellen können. Hier sieht man,
dass es aufgefordert wurde, eine
vollständige Simulation in SVG mit ein
paar verschiedenen prozeduralen Szenen
zu erstellen. Und das ist nicht das
Einzige, was es geschafft hat. Es gibt
noch ein paar andere Dinge, wie zum
Beispiel die Darstellung einer
Kaffeemaschine. Das Verrückte ist,
dass der Opus 5.5 Checkpoint sogar
besser ist als der Opus 5.2. Ich bin
mir nicht sicher, ob sie diese Version
veröffentlichen werden, aber es ist
verrückt zu sehen, dass Anthropic
diese unentdeckten, stillen Modelle hat
, die sie letztendlich gar nicht
herausbringen. Vielleicht tun sie es
bei der 5.5, aber es zeigt deutlich,
wie viel große Kraft derzeit hinter
diesen Bemühungen zurückgehalten wird
, Leute. Aber schauen wir weiter zu
StepFun, denn sie haben gerade erst die
Step 5 Preview vorgestellt. Das sieht
nach einem ernsthaften Konkurrenten aus
, denn dieses neue Modell, das sie
veröffentlicht haben, ist bei der
Preisgestaltung sowie bei den
Benchmarks extrem wettbewerbsfähig.
Step 5 Preview ist ihr nächstes
Flaggschiff-Modell, das stark auf
agentische Arbeit, Softwareentwicklung
und professionelle Wissensaufgaben
ausgerichtet ist. Das ist es, was
StepFun besonders hervorhebt, wenn es
um ihre Stärken im Finanzbereich geht.
Aber dieses Modell, das wir uns gerade
ansehen, ist ein riesiges MoE-Modell
mit 600 Milliarden Parametern, von
denen jedoch nur 27 Milliarden
gleichzeitig aktiv sind. Es bietet
zudem Vision-Support und ein
Kontextfenster von 1 Million Token. Was
jedoch wirklich heraussticht, ist das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis, denn laut
den eigenen Daten von StepFun
konkurriert Step 5 Preview auf dem
Niveau von Modellen wie GLM 5.3 und
Qwen 1.5 3, während es potenziell 65%
weniger pro Aufgabe kostet. Sie betonen
außerdem die Ausführung über lange
Zeiträume, was bedeutet, dass das
Modell darauf ausgelegt ist, wesentlich
längere und komplexere
Softwareentwicklungsaufgaben zu
bewältigen. Und während man die
Vorschau bereits über StepFun selbst
testen kann, ist der 15. Oktober das
große Datum, auf das man achten sollte
, da sie an diesem Tag die Gewichte
veröffentlichen wollen. Der einzige
Haken ist die Größe, denn ein Modell
mit 600 Milliarden Parametern lokal
ausführen zu wollen, erfordert
natürlich einige ernsthafte Hardware.
Und selbst mit Quantisierung wird es
praktisch unmöglich sein, dies lokal
auszuführen, weil es einfach ein
massives Modell ist. Aber sobald diese
Gewichte verfügbar sind, werden wir
definitiv sehen, was die Community aus
diesem Ding herausholen kann. Ich werde
euch definitiv auf dem Laufenden halten
, was sie am Ende mit diesem Modell
veröffentlichen und was ihr
tatsächlich lokal damit anstellen
könnt. Als nächstes sieht es so aus,
als ob die Veröffentlichung von
MiniMax M 3.1 kurz bevorstehen könnte.
Hinweise auf MiniMax M 3.1 sind nun in
Testdateien eines geheimen Commits
aufgetaucht, der im
MiniMax-Code-Repository gefunden wurde,
welches ebenfalls gerade
veröffentlicht wurde und Open Source
ist. Natürlich bestätigt dies noch
kein Veröffentlichungsdatum oder
ähnliches, aber es ist ein starker
Hinweis darauf, dass MiniMax an ihrem
nächsten Modell arbeitet, dem M 3.1.
Nach dem, was ich gehört habe, scheint
es derzeit vorbereitet zu werden. Wir
sind also sehr nah dran, dass sie die
letzten Handgriffe für diese
Veröffentlichung vornehmen, und
vielleicht sehen wir das Modell noch
Ende diesen Monats oder Anfang
nächsten Monats. Während der
Zwischenergebnis-Konferenz von MiniMax
am 26. August erklärte der CEO, dass
mehrere kommende Modelle, darunter
MiniMax M 3.1, M3 Pro und H 3.1, kurz
vor der Fertigstellung stünden. Dieses
M 3.1-Modell scheint sich weniger auf
die reine Skalierung zu konzentrieren,
sondern mehr darauf, es für reale
Anwendungsfälle extrem zuverlässig zu
machen. MiniMax gibt an, dass sie
Stabilität, Ausgabequalität,
Inferenz-Effizienz sowie die
Verallgemeinerungsfähigkeit von
Agenten optimieren. Im Grunde versuchen
sie, ein Modell zu bauen, das ihre
breitere Infrastruktur zuverlässig im
großen Maßstab betreiben kann. Aber
bei M3 Pro wird es richtig verrückt,
denn MiniMax sagt, dass dieses Modell
fast 3 Billionen Parameter umfasst und
ein großes Architektur-Upgrade
enthält, das Bereiche wie
Pre-Training-Skalierung,
Trainingseffizienz und Aufgaben mit
extrem langen Zeithorizonten
voranbringen wird. Wenn dir dieses
Video gefällt und du den Kanal
unterstützen möchtest, kannst du eine
Spende über die Super Thanks-Option
unten in Betracht ziehen. Oder du
kannst unserem privaten Discord
beitreten, wo du monatlich kostenlosen
Zugriff auf verschiedene Abonnements
für KI-Tools erhältst. Dazu gibt es
tägliche KI-News, exklusive Inhalte
und vieles mehr. Und das ist nicht die
einzige KI aus China, an der gearbeitet
wird, denn Alibaba arbeitet an Qwen-4,
und es könnte schon bald erscheinen,
vielleicht schon nächste Woche, da
Alibabas kommende Aspara-Konferenz
nächste Woche stattfindet. Dahinter
steckt tatsächlich eine gewisse
Geschichte, denn Alibaba hat frühere
Aspara-Konferenzen genutzt, um wichtige
Qwen-Generationen vorzustellen,
darunter ihr 2.0-Modell aus der
Tongyi-Modellserie sowie Qwen 2.5 und
Qwen 3. Es besteht also eine reale
Möglichkeit, dass wir dort auch die
nächste Generation sehen werden. Die
Konferenzagenda macht das Ganze noch
interessanter, da es eine komplette
Session namens „Advancing Qwen
towards agentic AI“ gibt, in der
Alibaba das neueste Flaggschiff-Modell
mit großen Verbesserungen bei Coding-
und Büro-Funktionen vorstellen will,
neben einem neuen Omni-Modell und einem
Echtzeit-Übersetzungsmodell für
mehrere Sprachen. Interessant ist
jedoch, dass für die Aspera-Konferenz
noch weitere kommende Modelle
angekündigt wurden, wie zum Beispiel
die Vorschau auf Happy Oyster 2, ihr
World-Modell. Sie veröffentlichen
außerdem einige verschiedene
Audio-Modelle, wie ASR, TTS und
Echtzeit-Funktionen. Und dann haben wir
noch ein neues Bildmodell, das
tatsächlich schon vor dieser
Aspera-Konferenz veröffentlicht wurde.
Das ist Qwen Image 2.1. Dies ist ein
neues Open-Weight-Bildmodell mit 7
Milliarden Parametern für die
Generierung und Bearbeitung. Und das
Verrückte daran ist, dass es nur 7
Milliarden Parameter hat. Wir haben
viele verschiedene Rückmeldungen von
Nutzern gehört, die dieses Modell
getestet haben und sagen, dass es im
Grunde auf Augenhöhe mit Nanao Nana 2
ist. Und das finde ich einfach
unglaublich. Trotz seiner extremen
Leichtigkeit hat sogar Midjourney
erklärt, dass es mit vielen ähnlichen
Modellen konkurrieren kann. Es ist ein
Modell, das bis zu 10 Referenzbilder,
High-Fidelity-Bearbeitung und sogar
native RGBA-Transparenz für Bilder mit
transparentem Hintergrund unterstützt.
Und das Beste ist, dass die Weights ab
sofort verfügbar sind, was es zu einem
ziemlich leistungsstarken Modell macht,
das man selbst ausführen kann. Und zu
guter Letzt sieht es so aus, als
könnte Kimi Cat 3.1 bald erscheinen,
da der offizielle Kimi-Account von
Moonshot AI wahllos eine lange
Zahlenfolge gepostet hat, die im Grunde
keine Erklärung hat, aber die Leute
haben schnell erkannt, dass die Zahlen
perfekt zu Pi passen, wenn man die
anfängliche 3.1 weglässt. Im Grunde
scheint der gesamte Teaser also nur auf
eines hinzuweisen: Kimi Cat 3.1.
Natürlich wurde noch nichts offiziell
veröffentlicht, aber eine
Veröffentlichung steht kurz bevor, da
sie sich nun auf das Marketing und die
Vorschau der Highlights dieses neuen
Feature-Modells konzentrieren, das sie
bald herausbringen werden. Aber das war
es auch schon, Leute. Ich hoffe, euch
hat das heutige Video gefallen. Werft
einen Blick auf den World of AI
Insiders School Club. Schaut euch den
World of AI Benchmark und die Vibe
Coding Plattform an. Schaut euch
unseren zweiten Kanal an. Abonniert den
Newsletter. Kommt auf den Discord.
Folgt mir auf Twitter. Und zu guter
Letzt: Abonniert unbedingt den Kanal.
Aktiviert die Glocke für
Benachrichtigungen. Gebt diesem Video
ein Like. Und schaut euch bitte unsere
früheren Videos an, damit ihr bei den
neuesten KI-Nachrichten auf dem
Laufenden bleibt. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken, Leute, habt einen
großartigen Tag. Verbreitet
Positivität, und ich sehe euch bald
wieder. Macht’s gut, Leute.